Speaker 1: Let's go to Noah from Fort Lauderdale.
Noah, what is how are things down there?
The craziness was just getting going when
I left Miami about a month and a half ago.
Speaker 2: Oh, Mr. Pacman, you have no idea.
It's crazy.
I would almost go as far to say as diluted,
Speaker 1: diluted or diluted.
Whichever works, OK, good, it may be both,
yeah, what's going on?
Speaker 2: I had a question about the so I
was never really a political guy until covid
hit.
And when covid hit, I started essentially
studying right wing media because I knew the
circus was going to be great.
I'm curious to know if you if you have a connection
or at least a connection that I drew about
like right wing agitation about Comilla campaigning
for Newsom over Trump, campaigning for Roy
Moore.
Speaker 1: So if so, is there an analogy between
the two?
Speaker 2: Yeah, I, I think there is where
a lot of Republicans would support Roy Moore
after all of the insane allegations.
But now there's even more outrage that Comilla
is campaigning for Newsom.
Speaker 1: Oh, I see.
So you're saying is it possible that Kamala
Harris is supportive?
Newsom will hurt Newsom.
Yes, I mean, it's really just it's an empirical
question nationally, Kamala Harris is not
polling very well.
My guess is that in blue states she's polling
better and that in her home state of California,
she's polling even better.
My guess is that the numbers have been looked
at by the Newsom campaign and they've made
the call that it's better for her to help.
But I understand the concept.
If people don't like her, they might be turned
off.
But here's the thing.
If you kind of like Newsom, but you don't
like Kamala, I don't think that her campaigning
makes you go vote for Larry Elder.
You know, so so I'm not hugely concerned about
that.
Speaker 2: Well, my my big concern is, like
I said, I've essentially been studying right
wing media.
And I'm sure you're familiar with Candice
Owens.
Of course.
Have you seen that she's put out a statement
essentially saying that a national divorce
is inevitable?
Speaker 1: You mean like like the country
splitting into two countries?
Speaker 2: Yes.
Speaker 1: Oh, I don't care what she says.
I don't know that she's ever been right about
anything.
And she's one of the biggest investors I know.
So I couldn't agree.
She says, yeah, OK.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Thank you, Mr. Pakman.
Long time listener, first time caller.
Got a lot of respect for you in the show.
Speaker 1: Thank you.
All right.
Stay safe in Florida.
It sounds crazy down there.
Oh, no promises.
All right.
Very good.
Let's see who else we could chat with today,
because there are so many people that want
to get on today.
Let's try.
Let's go to Greg Piech.
Greg, Piech.
You're on the air.
Speaker 5: Hi, David.
So I'm actually I've been on in queue for
a while, and you took a break.
And I was so surprised because it lasted like
less than five seconds.
Why did you need to take such a small break?
I would think you did like at least five to
10 minutes for a substantial break.
Speaker 1: Yeah, no, that's true.
I like to keep the breaks very short.
And by the way, are you running a lathe in
the background?
Speaker 5: Oh, you can actually shoot.
You got me David Pakman.
My audio is not perfect.
I'm sorry.
Speaker 1: All right.
Did you have a question today?
Speaker 5: I guess I had a real question.
Have you ever considered, like, writing books
like Thom Hartmann, who's written a lot of
books?
Speaker 1: You know, I have I'm currently
in discussion now about a book.
And the question with the book is, what is
the book about?
You know, so I want to make sure I'm doing
something like I don't want to just throw
together a book in a month like some people
have done.
And it's sort of like of no value whatsoever.
But I do.
I am I am currently exploring different ideas
and treatments for a book.
OK, sounds great.
Thank you.
Now, are you willing to tell me what is the
power tool that's running in the background?
Speaker 5: It's a it's an air filter.
I, I just picked one up because I was worried.
I get allergies.
I haven't had problems with that.
And I just leave it running all the time for
like better air quality.
Speaker 1: OK, do you feel that your allergies
are better with Iran?
Speaker 5: Yeah, I think it works.
Good.
Speaker 1: Good.
All right.
Thank you so much for the call.
Yeah.
All right, well, sort of a slow deceleration
on the calls today, but I do appreciate everybody
I was able to speak to and I look forward
to speaking to more people again.
Next time we take calls, we'll go to a break
and be back right after this.